now amid the latest Witch Hunt and
predictable media mob frenzy that has
ensued how is the Trump family well how
are they reacting to the indictment here
now with some insight former former
president Trump's uh daughter-in-law
Laura Trump is back with us I know Eric
was on the plane with him I talked to
him on my radio show today
um it's kind of surreal I've got to
imagine your family's been through a lot
Laura I mean Mueller uh stormy stormy
you know this has all gone on for years
not one but two impeachments they've
done everything humanly possible to
destroy your father-in-law and now this
is the next step you know making up law
that never was used before in an attempt
by the way with the statute of
limitations passed in an attempt to take
down your father-in-law yet once again
yeah I mean it just goes to show you I
think Sean how afraid they really are of
Donald Trump when you have to go so far
as to make up a crime and piece it
together with Scotch tape to bring down
Donald Trump because you just said it
they've been trying to do this for years
for almost seven years now to take him
down
um it's rather amazing but yeah it is a
little surreal to to truly think that
this is where we are right now in the
United States of America and I think
it's frightened a lot of people I think
it's it's awakened a lot of people you
know as of 72 hours post-indictment the
Trump campaign raised seven million
dollars that is an incredible statistic
and I said on Friday on your show that a
quarter of the donations were from first
time Trump uh supporters they had never
donated ever to the Trump campaign in
any campaign so it is rather amazing to
see the support from people out there
even with Sarah Carter's interviews
there in the liberal Bash question of
New York City to hear that people really
do get it well I hope the people that
ultimately are picked on the jury get it
as well and see it as a political
persecution and not a real trial not
based on real law
um I'm watching I want to get your
reaction and I know Eric was on the
plane with your father-in-law and your
reaction to the OJ like coverage of all
of this uh OJ of course accused of
killing two people
and the driver of the car is saying he's
got a gun and he's in the back seat he
may kill himself okay this is over a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar NDA
about an affair that both sides agreed
never happened even after the money was
paid so Mike I mean that's got to be
surreal to you and your entire family
the the craziest part Sean I think is
after landing in New York to see the
entire New York police department in
full force mobilized lining the streets
I mean this must have cost the taxpayers
of New York tens of millions of dollars
the security coverage for this situation
and you just said it over what over a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
completely legal non-disclosure
agreement payment you know these things
happen all day every day in the United
States of America and the sad part is
that Alvin Bragg of course the district
attorney there in Manhattan is supposed
to be locking up criminals supposed to
be keeping the streets of New York safe
yet this is where all of the energy
focus and taxpayer money is going we
know their investigation has been years
long into my father-in-law they've been
trying to find anything possible on him
and here we are on the eve of his
arraignment obviously he will go down to
the courthouse tomorrow he'll be be
frank fingerprinted I assume there will
be a mug shot taken and all over
something that was not a crime the only
crime that Donald Trump committed of
course was winning the 2016 election
without the help of the swamp and the
establishment it says on drudge mugshot
of the century and Pete hack says my
friend colleague made a good point on an
earlier show and he said that will that
will probably become the biggest selling
Trump 2024 t-shirt out there and I'd
probably add hats and other swag with it
as well but uh I think that will
backfire on people because when people
look at the insignificance of the issue
and you know a law that had never been
tried used before and the length and the
depth and depravity of this and you know
indictment to begin with and then to do
this to a former president I do believe
there will be a backlash I mentioned two
polls that show a 20 increase in in the
president's approval rating and and poll
numbers since the indictment so I think
that's going to tell us a lot
I think it will I think you're right I
think uh that mug shot will probably go
down in history as the most famous mug
shot ever to exist in America for sure
um but I think people really get it and
they they see Donald Trump as a symbol
really if Freedom as a symbol for all
the the freedom-loving Patriots in this
country let's face it he has stood up
against all different kinds of attacks
throughout the time he ran for president
the first time the second time while he
was in the white house and he continues
to stand up in the face of all of it
despite all of this they want him to
quit they want him to give up they want
him to stop and he refuses to do it so
what do they have to do they have to
make up charges they have to bring them
up to New York spend tens of millions of
New York City taxpayer dollars all for
nothing it will only make him stronger
it will only make him more popular and I
think it will solidify him as the 47th
president all right Laura Trump thank
you for being with us as the Great when
Mark Levin says a
post-constitutional America hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else